the Kardashians are in here home and
this Kardashian turns 39 today I'm just
so excited living in the moment Kim
kardashian-west is feeling the birthday
love from her famous fan momager Kris
Jenner kicked off the birthday tribute
and posted this cute throwback pic
captioning you are such a force of
nature
thank you for shining your bright light
on everyone you love I learned so much
from her sister Khloe celebrated Kim's
birthday by saying there has always been
a magnetic energy about you you've
written your own set of rules always
would love and everyone loves each other
I'm rolling with it the reality stars
little sister Kylie shared this gorgeous
snap caption I'm so blessed to have you
in my life your love guidance
selflessness and loyalty are unmatched
and speaking of Kylie she was on hand as
Kim's personal makeup artist over the
weekend my birthday
I have a special makeup artist today
okay that's right the Keeping Up with
the Kardashians star got the party
started early on Friday night giving us
a peek inside her birthday dinner which
featured pink balloons and a centerpiece
reading happy Kim day
after dinner it looks like him and her
besties ended the night with a fun game
of cards against humanity' everyone
always asked like what's next and I'm
like I'm just gonna focus and do what
I'm doing
[Music]
[Applause]